hello and welcome to episode 43 of
GameSpot after dark game sports official
video game podcast I'm your host Jake
Decker and joining me this week is Kelly
plaguey
jean-luc safety I already finished my
beer and we haven't even started hell
yeah is gonna be a good episode and
Michael hi um I'm making my triumphant
return to GameSpot after dark
hell yeah kazoo playing a cool game
which we'll talk about later about but
before we do that how are you all doing
that's how you do it yeah I'm doing I'm
doing quite alright feels good to be
back on the podcast he's better laughs
oh [ __ ]
well it's made out of glass the bottles
made out of glass anyway we're really
excited that you're back on sorry I
interrupted your awesome it's all good
it's all good
let's play that first episode in a long
time where we don't have any British
people you're damn right I mean we only
had one really before you know just a
more oh yeah yeah I do miss I miss
talking to Tam though I mean GameSpot
after dark can have one dark person as a
treat well why don't we just get into
what we've been playing after that yes
you go first calli
almost about animal crossing I have good
news everyone I'm playing a game that's
not animal crossing I'm still playing
animal crossing of course the bad news
is I can't talk about it I'm playing The
Last of Us part to me I'm rewatching
avatar last airbender it's my favorite
show in the world I
I am also playing Last of Us too and I
too cannot talk about anything but we
will talk about the state of play I
think we're gonna let Michael and John
Luke take point on that though sure but
Kelly and I both did watch it actually
might feel I actually didn't watch it
because at this point it's so close to
release that I was like
rather just I know I'm gonna play the
game I don't really want to see yeah I
haven't finished the game yet and I was
really worried that the state of play
would show things that I haven't played
yet but it did it so hundreds of Vita in
the game yeah there is a Vita and with
hotline Miami
yeah there's ice cube ice qu out uh it
was a good day makes makes an appearance
and yeah Scott's got some good music
going on but a look the Vita the Vita
player like she got her foot in its
throat stabbed bro like that's savage
man I made a random tweet about my Vita
on the weekend and it got like 900 likes
and I was like what's over yeah I was
like what the [ __ ] like why are you now
you know where to get cloud dude
just keep lives well how do you think
Greg Miller is as big as he is a point
yeah
like listen the Vita has like Vita fans
have strong there are dozens of us
energy mm-hmm but there are actually
more than dozen I really I love handheld
so I am also somebody who likes Vita and
if I found a Vita in the apocalypse you
bet that I would try to charge it and
see if it had hot it's a really nice
piece of hardware it's a thing I was
thinking about this like everyone was
like wow the Vita like still it could
hold a charge and I'm like more
importantly like you could only play
games that don't require like updates to
play like yeah it has already been
downloaded I was like we have to find
cartridges a bleak bleak world oh it
doesn't have that that a like Sony
memory card that was like dietary like
play Duncan rappin was like $200 for
like 64 gigs something like do things
like that yeah did you see I thought it
was pretty good
polygons tweet was like it was like
Ellie kills the last PlayStation Vita
owner
that's pretty good I'll give you that
one polygon nothing else you could have
that one is a treat as a treat train
today I just got to get out of my system
somehow I don't talk to anyone outside
of this apartment so y'all y'all gotta
save me thank you thank you I'm savoring
this one but before we talk too much
about last of us why don't we talk about
what you guys have been playing John
Luke do you want to start yeah I put
down a couple things I don't know which
one you guys are interested in I've been
playing so I beat maneater I played that
nice shockingly good game right yeah
shockingly good char king lee-char
kingly good real good
I got nothing we had a we had a field
day with the sharp oh yeah I saw they
were trying to come up with like
subheads for the review so like Edie
came up with seafood and eat it but I
could only come up with Finding Nemo
related things so I was like shark bait
ha ha and what was the other one
Oh Fisher friends not food I put
something in this your food not friends
you did put something Oh baby
it's a [ __ ] banger bro you know I'm
saying you really are into baby shark
you ready baby shark a lot dude that's
my guy baby shark or what I just saw my
brother approaching I'm gonna ask him to
get me another drink
Wow damn sushi give me another drink
well man you'd like Manny er then cuz
you play as a baby shark and then you
grow up right and they grow up yeah yeah
dude that games wild like I I thought
honestly like I played it at first I was
like I don't know about this one like I
feel like I would be like oh it's shark
simulator or whatever yeah and it's like
the combats pretty repetitive like I
think that game doesn't have the best
impression like when you're the baby and
it's just like I don't know like you
have one attack button you die from like
an alligator like super quick and I was
like
know about this but as you get on I
think the like the environments get a
lot more interesting you start like a
swampy bayou
but then like eventually you're like oh
now I'm in like this cityscape where
there's like people on a golf course and
you just jump in the air and then you
fly like you have like a triple jump
which is like ridiculous and then you
see a guy like off a golf car and then
you just like she'll be like combo chain
from a person a person and you're just
eating them all and then uh chris
parnell like Jerry from like Rick and
Morty is just like he's he's playing
like a like a planet earth type narrator
and he's just just like talking about
like very serene you know a man like
encroaching on nature and us getting our
comeuppance as the shark is just
devouring people it's so good that's
what I'm so good I prefer to think of
him as Chris Parnell from lazy Sunday or
Cyril from Archon or from that's what we
get more ease the hip one with the kids
and you know I gotta get that SEO but
yeah I mean like it's it's like the
formula is very typical Ubisoft you know
like checklist to go to each area but
it's so brief like I I beat the game in
about six hours is what my run time said
and I didn't do everything I just
basically like did it until like you
unlock the next door EB and then you
just keep going and the game's got this
like wonderful mix where the whole
conceit is like this Discovery Channel
style like show where there's like this
crazy shark hunter who like kills your
mom and like rips you out of her while
like she's pregnant with you and then
throws you in the water and you're like
bite his arm off and then like so the
whole game is like you gotta kill the
guy who killed your mom it's like a it's
like a JRPG I gotta play this it's great
and then and then the whole game I've
been thinking about it like it's got
this really the game I mean the game
knows what it is it knows it's like okay
we're just a dumb shark game with like
gore
and like that's all we are but at the
same time like it it commentates on how
it knows that so like it has these weird
moments where it's like I'm literally
eating the rich and like Chris Parnell
will make all these commentaries about
how like yeah you're like a killer
man-eating shark but like man is the
real monster because it was like toxic
like runoff in the water that probably
like made you is like vicious as you are
and like like that it like it knows that
it can't actually say anything
meaningful but also says that in the
game where it's like it's like okay you
know man's like overindulgence in
society is what's causing this like you
know current climate crisis were in but
you know like whatever you're just
seeing people and that's fun to like
that's kind of the game goes for I'm
like okay I'm here for that like that's
great they [ __ ] up the water so you
[ __ ] them up yeah it returns really
cathartic like if you just imagine like
I don't know you just like think about
all the people like the rich people that
you hate and you're like yeah I'm eating
them this area so I'm saying listen when
I when I make it up to the next tax
bracket don't come after me bro I'm good
the third yeah and then I went to a more
tame game with saints row the plane that
remaster I got it looks impressive I got
feelings on it it's weird it's it's um
so it does look initially impressive I
think I like the changes to the lighting
and and like when you're driving around
the city or like oh it looks great
I don't like the faces like I feel like
they they messed up where they redid
everyone's character models and they
like technically look better still
excuse me Oh technically but you still
but something about when they're moving
like their mouth movements are very
stiff and they're not expressive
and I'm playing it with Georgia who's
never played it before and we're like
the audit the writing is honestly still
very sharp like it's it's juvenile but I
think like the best writing is because
it's more playing off of like the
personalities of the different
characters and how ridiculous they are
and I think that stuff holds up super
well but I feel like the cutscenes
honestly get hindered by like the the
weird changes to any value yeah it's
like the character models look better
but then the lip-sync is like worse and
stiff so I feels like some of the line
delivery doesn't hit the same way it's
really weird I I think I prefer the
original bit specifically because of the
cutscenes like like like when you're
just just driving around the city it
looks better but I think that game's
cutscenes and humor is such a huge part
of it and I think it I think it suffers
unfortunately which is bums me out I
it's still worth playing like you know
if you've never played Saints Row it's
definitely not a bad option but it I
feels weird
what about like is the Kanye West
sequence is that oh it still hits that
still hell it still hits so good oh dude
the soundtrack in that game awesome
fantastic they have okay so you know the
characters Deimos who's like the
auto-tuned character he just talks
entirely and auto-tune yeah that is
funnier now than it was back in 2011
2011 that was like okay auto-tune like
that's the current thing now you're like
that's so so dated that it's funnier now
like it's way funnier so I think like
[ __ ] like that she'll like jump it out
of the helicopter to power I mean the
whole I think the music in that game
like the all the stuff on the radio is
like really good but yeah I am amazed
that we haven't seen a Saints Row 5 I
think they announced one right like kind
of quietly announced in a while she did
it like I that's what I heard somewhere
or maybe they were just like job
openings or something like that that
like hinted at a Saints Row 5 but I
always thought those games sold pretty
well and I mean we like obviously they
didn't like below people's socks off
I feel like I had fun playing all them I
don't think I played for people love 3:3
was like a huge breakout hit was it it
was great too is my favorite though but
it's busted on PC that's the one that
needed know to like needs a remaster
like legitimately for sure
was it three or four where they sent um
games journalists like the purple dildo
that's three oh I thought it was what
there was also was it saints row where
they sent brass knuckles or is that
something way before there is there's
something yeah I lose track of her like
we are the wacky PR stuff for games but
the the saints row I remember because I
was I had I was working at IGN like like
close to the release of Saints Row 3 not
like super close but like I remember it
was a thing it was like we finally got
rid of the dildos okay so so Jake the
official Saints for Twitter on April 6
said a new saint's row game is in
development from volition so ok they are
working on one apparently because like
they've been kind of quiet Felicia has
been kind of quiet this generation right
now man they made they made that great
game other than agency may agents of
mayhem yeah it's the only one that comes
to mind which was bad and officially a
sane throw in the saints row cannon yeah
it was disappointing because it was just
like this isn't really I don't know it
just seems so weird like they seemed
like with the same serial games they
were on the verge of like hitting like a
really good high and then that game came
out and I feel like they've been pretty
quiet just like remastering releasing
the games on switch and stuff yeah which
is good but I very curious to see what
they could do today it's part of that
like just approaching the end of a
generation to like it's it's a better
use of time probably for a lot of
developers to be remastering things true
but I like throughout the generation in
general to you know yeah yeah that's
true I guess it's been a while since for
yeah it is it's weird that one was
across gen game wasn't it didn't it come
to 360 and
yeah it was it was like at the same time
here yeah speak that truth I mean I
always loved science no because I feel
like it is to me Saints Row is like the
the the alternate version of what GTA
could have gone you know like like like
when you think of like the ps2 era of
GTA and how it was like kind of goofy
but it was also serious enough and then
like with four they pivoted to like more
serious story stuff like saves roads
like if GTA one in the opposite
direction and just went as stupid as
possible so like it feels like it needs
to exist to like balance the two the two
games perfect okay damn my bad my
latency is better I guess
did you guys ever play 2004's punisher
game by volition no I've heard I've
heard good things about an effort so
like I the only reason I played it was
because I had a friend I still he's
still a good friend of mine but he loves
The Punisher so he he got this game and
I remember we played it so much but it
was by volition it was incredibly
violent but it was not based on the
movie at all it was just like a really
like cool and you were like what 12
probably I was way too young to be
playing that game but anyway there was
you do interrogations and there'd be
these brutal interrogations and the
scene would cut - it would cut to black
and white and like hide the really
violent stuff like you'd throw people in
wood chippers or stick their face in a
piranha fountain or piranha thing or
whatever and like in like the game would
cut to black and move away and you
wouldn't see that stuff up close but my
friend was like I know a cheat code to
get rid of black and white mode and I
was like what how do you do it and he's
like can't tell yeah and he kept that he
he held on to this for so long I never
figured it out cuz like I don't know I
like the internet existed right but I
didn't like the Internet where I was was
super slow I never was on the Internet
so I was just like how do I do this and
I be entering all these cheats I when I
went to Barnes & Noble I'd look at cheap
books to see if I could find this sheet
and then a couple years ago he's like I
just made
I'm like gamers we have left me hanging
for so long but anyway that game is
really interesting it's probably not
very good but like it makes a lot of
sense that it went from Punisher in 2004
then the Saints Row like that like
Saints Row kinda had that vibe to it or
like Punisher you could tell that they
were head in that direction with how
over the top and ridiculous Punisher was
even though was still kind of like a
serious angry Marvel hero oh my god
anyway that's my head I'm Punisher I had
a roommate who was really into Saints
Row and we had a fun time it's not it's
a really fun game like being in Georgia
we played maneater and we just went
right to Saints Row and like I don't
know it's just like you know man dude
after dark you can say whatever you want
heck yeah after bank job dropping bombs
on after dark yo yo Chavez you're on one
dawg nobody's messaged me I keep being
like one day man someone's gonna hit me
up yeah like at work you mean yeah yeah
some could be like some little slack
you'd be like yo you you need to relax
yeah but like nope until someone says
something like you good I mean you guys
remember the Mario karts dream yeah ever
said anything to me I literally said eat
my ass toad on an international women's
day trouble so like hmm we say stuff
like that but we are not problematic
yeah
we're within reason yeah if you try and
press us on it like yo we got our
arguments are watertight a brawl away
you can't come after us for things like
that cuz whoa let you know just about
just like Saints Row yeah perfect
Michael you've been playing an
interesting game too right oh yeah if
you want to do a complete 360 or I mean
180
whatever yeah so colorful 900 baby
Tony Hawk yo cuz if you do a 900 you
actually be facing the other direction
by the end of it so that makes sense
thank you for that but man yeah Manny
yeah cuz 1080 would put you with do
three is three full spins yeah yeah
because seven hundred is 720 is two
spins and then a 900 is another
two-and-a-half year 900 oh hey by the
way you should check out my feature on
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater remasters saying
like yo back in the day when I was 10
years old she changed my life with music
and skateboarding because we around the
streets breaking laws that [ __ ] grinding
on on benches and sidewalks and [ __ ]
Napoleon ate [ __ ] out here I'm like eh
my ass pig so you know the vibes but to
do a complete 900 from sensor and
maneater
I played and reviewed if found thanks to
Cali for the opportunity to put my words
out on GameSpot calm but yeah if we want
to get into it it found is sort of this
I guess more or less a visual novel and
I'll talk about it as if folks don't
know what it is but the first impression
you get from is like it's it's this
sketchbook art style that's a lot of
pencil drawings a lot of contrasting
colors a lot of duotone and the way you
play the game is your cursor most of the
time your cursor is an eraser so you
play as this girl named Cassie oh and a
little story set up is that she's like
in her early 20s I think she's like 23
she comes back home she has a master's
degree she wants to get a PhD she comes
home and she did more or less like comes
from a broken home so her father's
passed away her mom's like yo when he
gonna like start your life get a job and
[ __ ] like that and her brother is a
total [ __ ] about the whole thing too
but yeah and then so you go through her
memories in December 1993
and it's it the whole thing takes place
and or most of the games takes place in
that month and you kind of see a drastic
change in her life during that time and
as you erase each scene another one
presents itself or it basically
progresses and it's used in really
clever ways to where it's it's it
leverages that to tell the story in a
very powerful way but and it takes place
in Ireland and the thing I like about it
one of the many things I love about it
is how how it adheres to Irish culture
so much like it'll drop terms they'll
drop
phrases and a lot of things that are
very particular like very very
particular to not just Ireland but the
region that the game play game takes
place in so County Mayo is on the
western side of Ireland it's it's kind
of like this this coastal area rural
small town and there are a lot of things
specific to it and it has like little
footnotes as you kind of you read the
text with each scene that passes by and
it was like a click here to have an
explainer for this and it's it in a way
I feel like the game is telling us like
let us bring you into our culture and
let us explain it so you can be a part
of this - it's really nice feature but
as the game progresses it's it's you
Cassio's like you go through all of her
all of our troubles and introspections
and all of her thoughts and feelings and
it's the thing I like about it a lot is
that between the writing and the art
style it I say this about a lot of games
or I say this about some games not to
make like a direct like undertale is a
very different thing but the thing that
if found does like a game such as
undertale is that it uses a lot or it
uses very subtle details and its art
style to communicate so much so a lot of
all the characters are drawn in like
like pencil edgings
and it's a and like the subtle shifts in
their expressions and their gestures
communicates so much because it's one
thing to read and text like Oh
this is how I feel about this person we
had this conversation this is what I
thought of it but when you see when you
erase each scene and you see the subtle
shift and like the way their eyebrows
are they're there how their eyes open up
how their hands move in relation to each
other like there's a lot of scenes what
are these subtle gestures it's it's
showing you not telling you exactly
what's happening and how Cassiel feels
about what's happening but it's uh yeah
there's you have a group of friends you
live in a like a dilapidated house for a
little while she's trying to find
yourself but I think the core of it I
mean you can read my review of like
billion words on it but I think the core
to it is how important empathy is in
terms of like you know not just
understanding people but being able to
relate to them and accept them and
acknowledge them for who they are I
don't think it's a spoiler but you
pretty much get the hint upfront and a
lot of people like anyone who talks
about if found is going to mention that
cassio is a transgender woman and so
it's a very the the story is very
particular to that and it's told in a
very subtle way that makes it all the
more powerful because it's it's in
little hints like letters that her mom
sends to her is like it's not that her
mom is being transphobic outright it's
more of like she doesn't understand
gender identity and it comes off as
transphobic whether she knows it or not
and that's I think that's a very like
powerful thing in the storytelling that
it doesn't spell it out for you
and rather the context clues all build
up towards that so then you realize like
you make the connection as the player to
realize like how much that hurts and I
think it can teach a lot of people about
things like that and when you come to
understand like especially by the end
the way it wraps up at the end it makes
its point very clear and like I keep
saying it I get it's it's very powerful
in that way and yeah the scenes are like
so it's
love the art style so much because it
reminds me so much of we know the devil
I was about yes absolutely I was trying
to put my finger on it and I just put it
together sorry to cut you off no no no
it's all good it's all good I I was
trying to find out if it was the same
artists I was looking I was literally
right now looking that up because I I've
been thinking about that because I love
that game and I was like the hurt
reminds me so much it I came it felt
like the thing that's gonna draw you in
is is that art I mean it is yeah
beautiful like that the sketch style is
beautiful yeah yeah it's uh and that
like they use a lot of different
techniques in terms it's because it's
not just like pencil drawings in a diary
it also sometimes it's like a pop-up
book sometimes it's this like this weird
mesmerizing surrealist style so it keeps
shifting and the one thing I'll say
about the what like how that works is
there's a scene where Cassio and her
friend like blaze up like they [ __ ]
ad like smoking on that dang drill bro
and then as the scene progresses their
their character the character models
like get wavy like yo I'm [ __ ] I [ __ ]
with them that's wild it's such a like a
small thing but again it like many
things in the game it communicates so
much with such a such a like a small
technique that you might overlook and
like one thing I really like about your
review of the game which even if you're
listening to Michael talk about it you
should still read the review oh yeah I
think that your review communicates like
the emotion of the game really well if
you really set the tone of the game with
your review because I think it's like it
sounds like a difficult game to describe
and I think you captured the be like
emotional weight of it really well
should oh yeah gang [ __ ] you know I'm
saying well ah yeah it was it was a lot
of fun or it's difficult to write to man
like because like you know talking about
things that like you're essentially like
I am a person who's playing this from
the outside looking in in a sense like
you when you play games that are from
the perspective of marginalized people
in the same way that
maybe other people play a game like
indivisible which is which I have
reviewed and like I made it very
personal because it means a lot to me as
a as a jungle Asian you know I'm saying
and so but what I think it's important
that it provides such a strong insight
into maybe a world that you're not
familiar with and does it in a in a way
that that can be relatable and teach you
a lot about things that you might not
know about so but yeah there's a million
other things I could say about the game
but I'll leave it at that
music is incredible some real nice
serene and post-rock jams in there and
yeah that's it's also only 12 bucks so
it's not like a full price game or
anything it's short to hours it's 2 or 3
hours and the wood the way it wraps up
is so nicely and the weight yeah it
flips its themes on itself throughout
the game like me short indie game like
Golden Age of like the early to mid 2010
like yeah mm-hmm like with gone home and
like you could just play like this
little like it was just this contained
experience and that's what it's found I
keep hitting the steps I'm sorry
that's what if found seems to me I'm
really excited to play it I don't
exactly have time right now but um I
will have time say tonight I really want
to play it yeah I think a la a lot of
people are looking for bite-sized games
because it's very daunting to go into a
50-hour game or a hundred hour game but
yeah this it it found uses its time
extremely well there's no filler it just
keeps hitting you with with good like
the good stuff I'll kill her no filler
man you know I'm saying
wait is that aspect that's the sum 41 no
okay yeah well speaking of 50 to 100 our
games I also reviewed Xenoblade
Chronicles and then embargoes finally
I've been playing that for the last
couple weeks now I had never played the
original I had always wanted to but when
it came out I didn't have a Wii and I
had I was not gonna get a Wii just for
it but I dabbled in other ones I
a bit of two and I enjoyed it I played
of it but I wasn't reviewing it so I was
like I don't I don't know if I want to
spend a hundred hours playing this but
luckily I got to review Xenoblade
Chronicles definitive edition Thank You
Callie for the Nintendo switch I saw
that is mostly what I've been doing
these past couple weeks and it is pretty
dang good I really really enjoyed it I'm
I kind of wish I did play it earlier but
at the same time I'm happy I didn't
because seeing the definitive edition
like I was looking at some character
models from the original and they look
pretty rough yeah yeah I think like one
thing that's that's really good about
having someone who hasn't played the
original game play the definitive
edition like obviously you have a an
appreciation for JRPGs you've played
plenty of games that are like xenoblade
chronicles and you've played other
Xenoblade games and i think that it was
a really good fit because like it's very
easy to go back and like i think you
were saying before the podcast that you
look look to the giant bonk quick look
for the original it's really easy to go
back and like make those comparison
notes for yourself like okay this
feature was in the original game where
it wasn't in the original game like how
has it changed from what I can see and
that I think is a totally viable way to
review a game and you have somebody who
has kind of like fresh eyes in 2020 how
does this game hold up and that's what
your review answers and you really go
into the combat like you don't just talk
about the additions and the new stuff in
the game you like really take a take a
fresh look at the you know play
carnivals as a whole yeah and I mean I
think like I liked it I had a fresh
perspective on the combat and all that
kind of stuff
but I think like the things that most
people are most interested in and
something that I spent a lot of time
talking about were all of the difficulty
options which you know typically isn't
something I'm sure people would spend a
lot of time talking about in a review
but I think it actually makes the game
really good because it's very forgiving
you can change it whenever you want you
can make the game harder you can make it
easier with casual mode and then from
there there are a lot of like
customization options with that mostly
in the form of expert mode which lets
you automatically adjust your levels
so you can if you're really good at the
game or if you just like to grind do all
the side quests you're gonna get over
leveled and this will let you you know
roll your character a couple levels back
to make the combat tougher if that's
what you want or you know alternatively
if you're stuck on a boss and you or you
just don't want to spend you know a
hundred hours playing this game you know
grinding for these boss you can just
switch to casual mode for a little bit
knock out some battles grind a few
levels much quicker than you would
otherwise and then just go back and
smash the boss not that kind of smash
the boss whoa whoa whoa relax
I know it's quarantine out here but you
know and we've seen some of the
characters and xenoblade chronicles -
yeah it's weird
they I'm talking about the one with the
giant we did animate cities actually I
don't know if it's a good but no like
they're like back-breaking and one from
- oh my god
yeah is absurd but it's really this one
with the new art style - like originally
it kind of felt innocent like the game
doesn't it's never that dark it doesn't
like dig into these heavy themes as deep
as some other games do but then you got
the xenoblade chronicles - and it's like
alright same style but we're gonna make
it a little more cartoony except all the
women in this game are just gonna have
massive tits which is it's interesting
going back to Xenoblade Chronicles 1
because everything seems more
appropriate I guess you could say more
fitting they were just both exactly bold
and brash we're like belongs in the
trash whoa
but yeah overall I really enjoyed it I
think the epilogue is a real standout -
it trims a lot of the fat and bloat from
the main game which by itself wasn't bad
because a lot of it you could ignore if
you didn't want to engage with it but
just the the epilogue just feels super
focused and refined and
you know monolith soft has always been
really good at creating these awesome
big worlds with really cool backdrops
and just a really impressive setting and
I think you can tell they've mastered
that with this DLC because the area
you're in is absolutely stunning
which is a lot to say like sure it's not
but graphically it's not gonna blow you
away like a PlayStation 4 game or an
Xbox 1x game but that said they like the
art style is just so good it's it's a
world that I was enjoying exploring as
much as I possibly could I have one
question I probably know the answers to
this is this for me yeah I think so yeah
I I think you'd like this game I I will
say like the biggest like thing for me
which I didn't really talk about in the
review was that it's kind of interesting
playing JRPGs that came out before
persona 5 and Dragon Quest 11 because
both those games are like some of the
best JRPGs out there and they improve so
many issues with like like they get rid
of so many issues and what's tropes
tropes yeah and Xenoblade definitely has
some of that stuff and you know the game
is 10 years old you can't like of course
that stuff is gonna be there yeah it's
like fundamental the way it's built yeah
like it's like a source of tropes
problem like yeah but I think like a
younger audience maybe who maybe not a
younger audience but an audience who
recently got into JRPGs may have a
difficult time getting into Xenoblade
but I think the one benefit is that now
that the combat you can adjust the
combat to make it much easier i think
that'll help because the original one
was hard and there were some boss fights
where I was just being stubborn and I
was like no I'm not gonna change the
difficulty I'm gonna do this boss fight
and I would grind for a long time and I
would spend I don't know probably like
half an hour in menus just tweaking my
characters so I could get the right
build to take advantage of this boss
which is super satisfying but I also get
there like
you know if you do that for the entire
game it can easily take 160 hours
mmm does changing the difficulty affect
like how much experience you get no at
least from what I can tell it seems like
you get the same so the reason why it
goes so much quicker though is because
you just battles go by like I don't know
some of them go by twice as fast so you
can just head out into the world and
kill monsters twice as fast get twice
the amount of experience just because
you're killing them faster and then you
can go back to the boss and fight them
so it's go ahead I just say interesting
how like definitive edition sometimes
make the JRPG faster like I just think
about Dragon Quest 11s was it it was
yeah it added the 2d version which like
significantly significantly cut down
like exploration time right yeah that's
yeah it's the the fast track version
yeah didn't persona 5 Royal it's oh so
no I'm saying is like you're right about
like the definitive versions of these
JRPGs always have an element where you
can go through things faster so persona
5 definitely like royal had that because
there's a whole bunch of new content
that you probably just want to like get
to especially for returning players but
even like all the trails of cold steel
games when they they initially come out
on like ps4 ps3 or PlayStation consoles
whatever when they get ported to PC a
couple years later they always implement
a fast-forward mechanic where you pull
the trigger and everything moves at like
4 times speed I'm like well why didn't
you all put that in the first place yeah
yeah zodiac Age did that too because
like there are a lot of elements that
are inherent to these games like maybe
the way you go through combat scenarios
to get to the next town or whatever and
like those things are good but they can
drag on and eventually I realized I
option like maybe it's better if we just
get through this faster so we'll give
you a fast-forward mechanic or make
things easier so it's it's funny how
that that that trend is definitely there
yeah or even ultrasone an ultra moon
like sped up the intro sequence like a
bunch and this was one thing that I it
didn't bother me at all when I reviewed
Sun and Moon I like didn't think that
they'd be good it's because I don't Soph
reset for like shiny starters or
anything like that I was just like I'm
reviewing the game yet I gotta go so I
like it didn't bother me at all but it's
a reputation those games have we're
having a really long to toriel intro
sequence and ultra so I'll turn like cut
it down like yeah I don't do any of the
exposition before you get your Pokemon
and I was like okay now I noticed it I
like the idea of remasters really like
looking not not just being like oh we've
added new stuff and it looks prettier
like actually like going back and like
fundamentally changing things like I've
been playing yeah like I've been point
I've been playing royal you know
personifies royal and I think atlas is
like very unique in the way they do
those kinds of like I don't know what
you'd even call it like Game of the Year
but not really like they'd raters cut
director's cut is maybe the best term
because they they add new stuff but they
also like are using as an opportunity to
like make changes based on feedback like
you know when the original five came out
there is the the meme about like Morgana
being like time to go to bed that
doesn't even happen in royal because
they cut all of that out because they at
they realized like they're like oh
that's funny but also people are making
fun of it because it kind of sucks so
like they added this mechanic where you
actually can do something at night now
and it's like I like the idea of games
actually like realizing like we can we
can improve the experience and like I I
think things like fast forwards or maybe
like a little more of a hotfix versus
like like you're sort of 5s a little bit
maybe more of an extreme example or they
like really overhauled it but it's still
welcome yeah well anyway do we want to
talk about bus as we kind of already
talked about it already and I know John
Luke you didn't really get to watch it I
don't mean there's any kin if you want
if you guys want to add I don't want to
say anything cuz already I'm connecting
dots that I can't
yeah Jake I really can't say anything I
mean but we'll have the opportunity to
talk about the Last of Us a lot more
yeah soon so like maybe we save it fruit
for that yeah I mean I don't think I
have that much more to add beyond what
everyone saw at the state of play I mean
like it's the last of us and it looks
and it looks like it plays really really
well like really well-crafted scenarios
with combat and all that like all the
options and how crafting has evolved and
all the different things Ellie can do
like those things are still impressive
but I mean at this point you know y'all
y'all playing the game I'm gonna have
much better insight and for me I'm just
like alright I'm I'm ready to play this
like I know what this is this is a known
quantity in terms like what kind of game
I'm getting into I just want to see the
drama and fight those those those
harrowing sequences and all the clickers
so man I don't know if I'm ready because
I'm [ __ ] know I I think the one
thing that like I can say is I think
like I would have said this anyway I
think people are really quick to judge
games now like these days based on these
like preview snippets that we could and
I I would say I was kind of guilty of
doing that with ghosts of Mishima
because before I dug into it I was like
oh this is interesting like they have
English dub but it's people using kind
of like exaggerated Japanese accents and
it's it's not a Japanese studio I'm a
little like Anton this and then I found
out that like the the studio did really
work with Japanese people to consult in
the game and and of course I didn't like
tweet a hot take or anything but like I
did wait to get that information and I
would say that like generally I think
that we could all like cool off on the
hot takes just based on like what were
presented I think there's something to
be said about like the way games are
marketed for sure and like you can say
like I did a preview for far cry
what number was it Ron with the Colts
five five five five I was like it wasn't
for was it five there's too many of them
but I did a preview on that just
specifically about like how could this
go well how could this go wrong based on
what I know about like the cult setting
and I was just talking about like a Waco
Texas and and stuff like that but like
so I think there's something to be said
for for those kinds of takes based on
the information you get initially but I
think there's kind of this current about
the Last of Us part two where people are
just ready to jump at like whatever hot
take their is based on on what they see
and I just think it's a trend that we
could do away with it's so weird it came
out of nowhere it feels like like
everyone was so excited for that game
and then the second that week happened
well yeah and when it got delayed to the
first that that second delay cuz this
was fun and they pushed it and they
delayed it again indefinitely and that's
when it started and I imagine that's why
people decided they should hack the game
and figure out just frustrates me
because my job is the reviews editor and
like the reviews is like we're looking
at the final product you're looking at
it as a whole and you're looking at it
as what it is you're not you're not
evaluating the marketing you're not
evaluating like what the expectation of
the game is you're looking at what the
game is in front of you and so it's
frustrating for me as the as a reviews
editor to see people like just like
tweeting these hot takes and I'm like
you don't even have the game you don't
like you you may very like you could be
right but like wait until you play the
game to develop your hot sake like it
just doesn't make sense the the perfect
example of that is like Matt pageant's
very excellent review of Rainbow six
siege I think I saw like a comment that
was like saying how like his reviews
invalidated because of that original
Ubisoft like III presentation from years
ago about what the game originally
looked and I'm like dude that was so
long ago like what are you talking about
like a I think you're right Cali where
it's like you could absolutely have that
conversation about like
Hey Ubisoft messed up I like presenting
that game in a way that it wasn't final
like I think that's a very valid
conversation but the idea that like a
game that's been out for what like five
four or five years at this point is like
still invalid because of that is like
that's insane like that's an insane
logic of thinking like the Marty is not
the development team right ultimate team
you know like that's a different team
and like there's just a lot mixed up in
it so yeah it was I just that's my I
will say I was modding the YouTube chat
as we were doing the last of a stream
it's just exhausting absolutely
exhausting it's just like you know
there's people so mad about a game they
haven't played because of things they've
heard on it's just like just either play
the game don't play the game I don't
care just stop complaining about it and
yeah it doesn't affect me one way there
is affecting me at the time because it
was just like meaning people complain
about stupid [ __ ] it's just like yo all
right I I say this many times and it
rings true I got you know put this on my
gravestone tombstone whatever the [ __ ]
you call it relax
saying it for so long since I was the
however the fuchal I was when I first
learned how to say relax but yo gamers
anyone out there
all y'all everyone can learn relax when
it comes to video games bro like these
video games yeah hi my favorite is like
people in the chat being like Neil
druckmann shouldn't be allowed to direct
any games anywhere and it's like it's
like wait you're invalidating this guy's
entire career you're ignoring it just
because of a leak you saw it's just like
anyway we should move on let's do some
let's relieve ourselves of this stress I
think I'm gonna see if this next one
because yeah yeah I'm gonna skip this
next topic and just go right into
listener questions this week sure this
one's not actually really a question
it's just a
email we got that I did want to read
actually does this one make sense to
read yeah I think it does yeah
Kelly do want to read this one yes this
is from Marcus the post see I'm a key
worker a postman my son is on the köppen
19 high-risk list so I cannot enter work
or have the social interaction I would
normally have
I feel practically alone I only see my
family and the odd person I deliver to
to talk to so thanks for the weekly
podcast having that show up in my
podcast list helps me get through the
day so I want to say thank you
shout out to Marcus and say hi to your
postman or postwoman as they come by I I
love that this this letter is so
obviously British a key word a postman
but yeah thank you so much for listening
Marcus and I'm glad that we can be a
bright spot this podcast is also a lot
of the socially socialization I get each
week so yeah it's the same for us all
right next question here comes from my
good pal Brett from discord Josh else
out the bread that's my guy mm-hmm
what's the one game that you would
what's the one game that would get you
to get oh my god I can't read can never
read I feel like I've been doing well
too it's cuz I always like set myself up
to get the short questions anyway what's
the one game that would get you to
upgrade to next-gen I don't plan on
buying a PS 5 for some time but if
something like horizon 2 or a ps5
exclusive I would consider upgrading
sooner what's the game that's gonna get
us to upgrade to next-gen it's a weird
one cuz I'm probably just gonna do it
anyway cuz I'm just yeah
person yeah it's a hard question because
we kind of have to upgrade for work yeah
so it's like it's hard to tell if I
weren't doing this job what would get me
to upgrade if Sony adds a PS 5 patched a
blood-borne that makes a run at 60 old
then I'll upgrade
that's a good one there we go I I had my
brother send me when I was in college
The Last of Us the first last of us came
out when I was in college and I had my
brother ship me are like launched ps3
from the Hat like my parents house
because I didn't bring up ps3 with me I
had an Xbox 360 but I didn't have like a
3ds but I didn't have like a any
PlayStation stuff and I I had him ship
it just so I could play The Last of Us
so I guess if the Last of Us part 2 were
an exclusive that would probably get me
to upgrade cuz that's what got me to
convince my brother to ship a whole
console to me the Last of Us remastered
is why I bought a PlayStation 4 like I
got an Xbox initially and then I waited
for the ps4 and I was like I'm gonna
wait until destiny and then I think it
kind of surprised announce the
definitive edition for Last of Us 2 and
I was like Last of Us remastered knows
like a right I I'm gonna pick it up for
that this one's hard too hard to answer
as someone who like keeps their PC up to
pretty high standards I guess because
it's like a lot of the features that
like PS 5 and Xbox series X are touting
are they are like legit upgrades from
what we have now for consoles and I
think a lot of people are going to be
surprised by I think they will be
surprised by the the the quality of life
changes that the experience will be when
you upgrade to these consoles but when
it comes to like how games look how they
run like I have an nvme SSD already I
know the console is going to be doing
something different so it's probably
gonna be better than what top-end PCs
happen now but I've been experiencing
that level of performance for a while
look I'm out I'm bawling out on my PC
Hatsune Miku yo okay if they if if there
is a like a mega mega mix that comes out
on PS 5 with like all the songs like
future tone almost got it right but they
have like 300 or like almost 300 songs
but there's some exclusive songs on the
switch and there are a bunch of other
songs that haven't been made into
- rhythm game like playable rhythm game
songs but if they do a ps5 bro you know
I'm gonna be standing out in the cold
okay but again I'm gonna be in my face
mask I got my gloves here y'all zombies
stiff-arming nobody's like yo if they
have them the most definitive ass
version of Project Diva has to make a
project diva you know it's a done deal
brawl is a song I'd like to sing on any
project diva I don't think so
ooh I don't think so see there's like a
there's so many I love I also would say
that I am a I'm just like a day one
Nintendo person so like I'm a dot like
it's kind of on its own generational
cycle and then for Xbox halo 100% would
get me to hail is a weird one though
because it's gonna be out on current gen
it's got to be out on PC but I want to
see this fantastic it's true you know
like it's full yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
been thinking about that - I think you
like halo infinite like yeah it's it it
is on Xbox one X and Xbox one X is a
fine console but like I would say if I I
am planning on upgrading my PC for
cyberpunk
but if I wasn't or for some reason I end
up don't like you know they're gonna
have that series X patch like I want to
see how beautiful that game could look
you know but I mean honestly like I feel
like ideally this like a weird cop-out I
feel like but like I I want to see like
a new game that like does something that
isn't possible on current gen like
showing what I will say is that I mean I
don't know exactly what this is but I
did an interview with the with Bluebird
team the developers of the medium and
they've made Blair which they made
observer and all that but they bid they
were pretty strong about how our game is
going to do something that's going to
leverage next gen like specifically it's
not coming out on Xbox one ps4 there's a
PC version and then Xbox series X only
who knows I don't know what that is
because they were they were
tight-lipped about said they'll mention
it later but my curiosity is like okay
then like yeah what is this and if it's
if it's impressive enough like okay
let's let's go then that's interesting
so then is it only Microsoft first party
games that will be coming to Xbox one
and Xbox Series X for a while because I
know these are smart delivery
well no just in general didn't they say
like you'll be able to play Halo on like
any first party Microsoft game you'll be
able to play on first party for sure
Ansel first part of it yeah third party
I guess they can kind of have an option
because yeah I'm interested in because
personally like I don't think I'm gonna
get the series X because I just updated
my PC to I put like two atti in there to
prep for cyber pumpkin it's like well
I'm just gonna play things you can write
like I probably won't upgrade like I'm
more interested in getting a PlayStation
5 honestly because I know they're gonna
have exclusives yeah that are going to
be made well I hope that are gonna be
made specifically for the PS 5 and a lot
of those games will pry in DUP being
like glorified tech demos but still like
I'm like at the beginning with console
generation I just want to see what I
want to be in on whoo yeah I have a
question are you subscribed to game Pass
I am subscribed to gamepad Bill
Spencer's Phil Spencer's happy with you
then I know that game Pass ultimate to
you hmm
me too yeah real gamers are you balling
out
next question John they don't read this
one uh yeah do you have a favorite video
game controller or peripheral mine is
the hitbox arcade stick because I play a
lot of fighting games and it's very easy
to travel with and that is from foggy
bear on the discord I'm gonna guess it's
foggy bear foggy barrack yo that makes
more sense also I should have pointed
out be foggy berry like you know if you
have any questions you can email it I
said after dark podcast that
gamespot.com or you can join our discord
you can DM any one of us on Twitter and
we will make sure to get you in there or
you can just email that email and we'll
get in there
anyway it's a weird one because I'm I'm
a weird stickler where I like playing a
game on like the the peripheral it was
like designed for so like the retail
yeah exactly like you got to get that
original setup right you know I got a
spot hundred thirty dollars but like I
don't know it's like there's a weird
thing where it's like oh I'm gonna play
Mario 64
like people are like I can emulate it
and you can use like a 360 control I'm
like no I want to use that that n64
stick that terrible terrible stick
because it's what it was designed for so
I don't know like I always like prefer
playing with the controller like the
game was kind of built around I don't
know if I have a favorite I feel you in
terms of like like proprietary
controllers or controllers that were
made specifically for a game I mean like
I need to play fighting games with with
a fight stick Eddy most of them will do
but I think my when it comes to like
peripheral especially as I've gone
through like so many different PC
peripherals like yo the logitech mx518
is undefeated it's the best Mouse ever
use I have a bunch of other Logitech
mice but like the mx518 oh they
remastered it so it was always the one
is the one that cut down grinding times
does it make it faster oh the the mouse
skates on the bottom or are better than
they were back in the day but back in
that game that mouse came out like 2003
it's still the best design I think but
uh yeah a logitech peripherals cafe they
got it right for me
but in that like I'll use a 360
controller you so Xbox one controller
use a ps4 controller I don't it's all
good to me I really want one of the
elite controllers for Xbox cuz I messed
around with them I'm like man these are
great but then I never like can pull the
trigger when I'm gonna buy it yeah this
is why this is why you have gamer
parents because my dad got me an Xbox
elite controller
and so that's how I got mine yeah it's
like one of those things you won't by
yourself but if you someone gave it to
your like a hell yeah my dad was like
like live in luxury like I really do
love that controller it is nice it is
fast but generally I mean I like like I
don't really have a super big preference
I guess I played undertale with a
trackpad like I I like I'll do whatever
I'm good yeah mmm that's that's not bad
when you're trying to like evade attacks
that's I could see that working bet I
beat genocide with a trackpad so yeah
put that on the that's a box quote right
I've defeated genocide with the track
damn shouts out to you I I just I just
thought of something right now
[ __ ] damn your camera did a weird
dramatic zoom - oh yeah it's like it
does this horribly effect oh uh I'll
just say Guitar Hero you you got me
knobs oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah like the
way the way it emulates guitar playing
is and Rocksmith like that shit's tight
so that was the other thing too like I
always thought the rock band guitar is
especially liked after the first wave
felt so much better than the Guitar Hero
guitars they just felt so much sturdier
and I remember playing with the rock
band guitar and then going back to like
my guitar hero guitar like the tiny
little like plastic one and I was like
it's just not the same size that's funny
because Georgia my girlfriend is the
exact opposite we she's been playing
like Guitar Hero we went to rock band
she's like I hate this controller it's
terrible
see I feel like if you're actually good
at rock guitar here I could see why you
may not go back to that was because I
remember they made like a bunch of weird
changes with like I guess like the the
frets were kind of sticky yeah I I
always had an issue reaching the orange
one oh my hands weren't big enough for a
really long time okay well let's move on
to the last question Michael do you want
to read this
it's longer yeah persona
Smt oh my god
damn damn damn alright yeah the the what
we are addressed as in this email is
just top chefs kiss that's why I didn't
read it I cuz I like until we actually
get on it to read but I saw that in turn
I was like yeah we got it
alright here it is let me try my best so
I can't read it I haven't read in a very
long time
greetings after dark nights KN nights
dark night like the movie maybe this is
too much of an inside baseball question
but I was wondering why it seems like
atlases too large series seem to play
for different teams persona and its
spin-offs predominantly show up on Sony
products and shin megami tensei smt has
been appearing largely unintended on
Hills it isn't a handheld versus console
scenario when the Vita PSP persona games
were coming out there were SMT games
released within the same time frame I
know there exceptions to the rule with
the persona q series and scramble coming
to the Nintendo consoles but B seemed
more like aberrations or distortions
have I see you the claw of the closest
thing that I can figure out is that that
it may have to do with atlases
publishing deal with Sega but I'm not
sure why Sega would be averse to
Nintendo money unless saying Sony is
just backing up enough dump trucks
backing up like a dump truck God dumps
like a truck truck truck a lot of fans
like what what of cash to keep the main
Persona series exclusive the root of
this comes down to figuring out why
often rumor persona 5 switchport
has never materialized and generally
curiosity general curiosity once I had
done some reading on the games if you
want a more fun question what creatures
from the series would manifest as your
personas wrong answers only or right
ones whatever is funny smart ank's
Andrew cut okay just in case y'all don't
know Mauro's a big-ass penis like a
chariot with a wheel a green slimy dick
do Isis straight-up all the demons in
Shin Megami Tensei would make excellent
tattoos absolutely yeah including Maura
including Maura but dudes like yak use a
back tattoo but most of us can only
speculate because there's no public like
yeah it's a record you have to be
careful I don't want to like mate assume
too much yeah I mean it's kind of like
patterns that we notice I guess I would
say like I think there's definitely a
pattern in Japan of like a series being
faithful to a specific platform you know
like I think that's kind of uh that
that's a bigger deal in Japan I don't
know if it's still as big of a deal
about you know like it was it was a huge
deal when Final Fantasy switched from
Nintendo to PlayStation like that was a
huge deal and I think like that that
thing kind of matter it's there so I I
mean there's no like hardcore contract I
don't that I'm aware of that like yeah
you got it there sona on this platform
because like oh you know all those
spin-off games get released on intend oh
they put outs which arena on xbox and i
so i imagine on some level it is a like
just like a like a legacy thing you know
maybe the developers just prefer working
on that platform you know they don't
really need to go to a different
platform yeah the persona 5 developers
there was something going around that
they like didn't think persona 5 would
be a good fit handheld like they wanted
that to kind of stay on that big screen
I don't know I heard that somewhere
that's fair I mean it's definitely weird
because like
persona has been not a handheld series
but like there was that weird stretch
where it was like golden came on the
Vita and then he had like queue and that
was like a lot of people's first
introduction so I think a lot of people
started to associate it more as a
handheld series even though in reality
it isn't one so I think like
I know that it may be created just like
a weird expectation on people of like it
so it's a handheld franchise and like
the developers don't think of it this
one as much yeah I like it likes like we
said there's those no there's no
evidence as to like whether or not
there's any contractual obligations but
there's a pattern because like the last
time Shin Megami Tensei was on on a on a
Sony console was with Nocturne which
came out in 2003 or 2004 of 2004 and
then from then on Shin Megami Tensei had
been relegated to Nintendo franchises
maybe like in the case of SMT maybe it's
like again this is a speculation but
like they scaled down on how much how
much how many resources they put into
the SMT franchise because SMT for and
for Apocalypse are handheld games
they're kind of like a not bite-sized
but they are focused scaled-down types
of JRPGs that were nob viously not made
with like a full console in mind so they
thrive on 3ds in that regard because
they are also very true to the original
SMT kind of style of game and so it's
like if they brought it to a major
console it wouldn't like translate as
well so having that and like it a 3ds
form they could stay true to what SMT
had always been without having the
burden of having to evolve the franchise
in some sort of big way now in the
regards to bringing like persona 5 to
switch I think the fans are vocal to a
point that it's a problem but if there's
if there's one thing to take aways that
the there is a strong desire for it on
intent of switch off there's a technical
reason or again it's like some kind of
contractual reasons but I I still don't
necessarily understand why if I've
wouldn't come switch but also maybe it's
also maybe a resource thing again they
just came out with royal and maybe
porting it to switch will take a lot
more work than Atlas and Sega are
willing to put in so yeah that's another
thing to consider when thinking about
this thing that SMT 5 is so SMT 5 is
going to be a switch exclusive Elly's
from
we know so far yeah they announced it
with yep three years ago yo this is old
not a damn thing about it
stop coming baby yeah I were on the
street is there's it's still in
development obviously but I'm wondering
I'm curious to see what what that game
actually turns out to be to see if like
okay this is made as a scaled-down
version in mind or not like a full-blown
console version in mine but again we'll
have to wait to see what SMC find
actually is I mean well yeah there could
be all sorts of reasons it could be like
oh we don't want to eat our own lunch
with so many have like you know yeah
yeah and and and and I think Michael you
made a good point of like I don't think
people realize how how much ports
actually like development resources and
money ports do you actually cost you
know like either you know the persona
team themselves would have to do it
which is eating into them working on the
next persona game or they have to hire a
different third to do a third party so
and it's like well you have to have a
lot of trust in giving it to another
studio to make rapport actually work
properly so it's like they might be like
very protective of their own bread this
does have a studio I think it's studio
zero that has done so good for them they
did the Catherine full body and they're
now working on project reef a nasa
project reef annecy so it's like they
have a team but that team's already
working on other stuff and for whatever
reason you know atlas felt that their
time was better spent on that stuff
versus a persona thing you know and yeah
honestly I think it comes down to like
you said the studio may be picking their
battles like where they can be most
effective and so you know it's tough in
the streets yo anyway I think that about
does it for episode 43 of GameSpot after
dark thank you so much for listening and
thank you guys for joining me if you've
got any questions make sure to email it
up email us at after dark podcast at
GameSpot comm or you can join our
discord by deeming us and we'll get you
in there
jean-luc where can people find you and
is there anything you want
ah you can find me at John excite key
potato mode me and me and Michael
recorded another potato mode where who
he not made me Michael Jesus what [ __ ]
I've known about this know me Nolan van
genka recorded a potato mode where we
looked at Mortal Kombat again because
the new aftermath DLC came out so like
we potato fide Robocop and all that
stuff and it was pretty good turned out
pretty well so look forward to that
Callie have you you could find me on
Twitter at a key doji Co I n KY d oj n
kk oh we have a lot of reviews coming up
on GameSpot at the end of the month
there's a lot of games coming out so
Xenoblade was one of those big ones if
found for Michael Michaels also checking
at PSO to and we got more and then of
course like keep an eye out for my Last
of Us review and please don't send me
any death threats I mean I just
expecting them I thought like I'm not
far enough and like I that's not an
indication of anything I just don't want
to get death through Michael hi uh uh
you could find me and all of my [ __ ]
at Michael P hi I'm on Twitter calm and
as far as work on GameSpot boy it's been
a while since I've been on after Drive
saw him plug all the way back to March
Bryan listen your blog review to
half-life Alex well make it quick
persona 5 royal how to make a project
diva megamix and as Callie said Maya
found reviews also up very proud of all
of those reviews but also play for all I
think Jake you're gonna mention it so
all of us here on this pocket like Jake
and John Luke gonna be doing a lot of
production work the heavy lifting for
that Callie and I Tam and Lucy we're
gonna be doing a lot of hosting stuff
we've got so much exciting stuff lined
up for y'all in lieu of III so yeah
we're gonna be doing a lot of work and I
think yeah if y'all like what we do man
we got some things lined up so pay
attention that we're all gonna be
working very hard to bring that to all
y'all out there cool you said it pretty
well therefore the play for all but you
can find me at jacob deck on twitter and
you can check out my zenith
Chronicles review which is up on YouTube
and GameSpot so make sure to check that
out anyway we'll see you next week peace
[Music]